you you two guys do seem like kind of
like disengaged lovers on this show you
have that kind of money
for an hour at least
now we're on the air alec it's all
business though there's a lot of subtext
with you guys i watch the show lately
and i go
what is it i can't believe it's a sexual
tension there there's a sexual you know
what it's attention
it makes it makes for good tv
it makes for outstanding emmy winning
television i find this whole
i find this whole little diversion very
disturbing i'm going to get off of it as
fast
as possible okay so don't you touch him
he's mine leave him alone all right i
can't control daddy
but stop make it stop
make it stop please make it stop alec
make it stop let's talk about
this movie is the getaway it's a remake
yeah
it's
[Applause]
i'm sorry um i'm sorry daddy um
no it's uh we did a remake of the steve
mcqueen movie and uh
and uh it really was great i mean i hope
people go see it because it's really
exciting movie
i mean it really just zooms along i've
never been much into like you know
action films you know
and we did this movie we have we have a
great cast we got jimmy woods
to do the filming michael madsen who i
really love as an actor and
uh um jennifer tilly and we got to
richard farnsworth so we got all these
really cool little people to do these
parts and it really is a good thing
this is a remake of a classic steve
mcqueen movie are you a steve mcqueen
fan
yeah i like mcqueen a lot yeah i thought
what's interesting to me is that a lot
of people have
it seems to me like mcqueen's been kind
of forgotten he was this huge star in
the early 70s you don't hear about him
that much
i think everybody before 1980 is kind of
forgotten now you know what i mean
so it's like i mean but people in the
movie business they really dig mcqueen
and what he did he was
i mean so many great films you know
papillon and great escape and uh getaway
was
bullet bullet great chase scene you're
telling brother you're telling me but
what greatest chase scene of all time
but
let's get back to the whole sex thing
yeah the audience was eating that we had
them and you let them go i know i know
i wanted to talk about mcqueen and i
blew it i apologize to all of you did
you have a thing with mcqueen when you
were uh when he was here
i was a little young at the time no no
oh
man make it go i've ruined the show um
now this is a return for you you've
worked for nbc before yes yeah oh yeah
you worked for you were sopa i did a
soap here and i did a soap in this
building for two and a half years
this is the doctor's of the doctors when
back in 81 82 around there
and a fun experience for you yeah
working in this building was fun working
at rockefeller
rockefeller center was fun oh you know
what's funny is i used to do this show
all these guys in the crew i mean a lot
of them are different now
because a lot of the guys in this
building they work on the uh on
all the different shows and i used to
work on the show and i came in i was all
excited it was my first job
and i said god you guys were at nbc they
got saturday night live they got
playhouse 90 used to be here and all the
guys in the crew were very very
nonchalant about it you know they would
say you know uh
you know this building alex this
building ain't the same way used to be
years ago so we had playhouse 90 and
then they all bowed their head in unison
very solemnly also then of course years
ago we had carson
and then carson moved to california and
everything whoa man
i think it's all downhill dead after
costco he did his show right across the
hall actually yeah johnny carson used to
be in this building
do you miss being a soap star
it's all downhill huh i'll get you
through it don't you worry
life has not been bad all right we're
gonna step away for a second when we
come back
you